foreign
is to not only meet but regularly talk
with share ideas with the true
luminaries of my field hi I'm young so
I'm a political scientist and I'm a sea
far as reality Global scholar CFR has
really allowed me to expand my Global
Network in several ways I get to belong
to a research program where I have
direct access to top senior Scholars
another way that cfar has expanded my
networks is through the other Global
Scholars many of them are in the Natural
Sciences and for these people I you know
I would never really get to meet them
naturally on my own so it's been an
amazing opportunity through cfar to get
to talk to them regularly one huge
benefit of being a cfar global scholar
is getting this unrestricted research
funding what that means for me is that I
can pursue much more ambitious projects
it actually helps me to apply for larger
grants later on so it allows me to prove
to other funding agencies that I can
take on these large projects because I
already you know have done it through
all of the resources that cfar provides
the unrestricted funding access to the
senior Scholars of my field and related
fields getting to meet all these other
peers in our Global Scholars having
professional development workshops all
of those resources put together has just
really Amplified you know our initial
potential into something much greater
[Music]
foreign